you guys
the homepod mini is officially here it's
a dream we don't have to wish for it we
don't have to hope it is here our wishes
and dreams have been granted i am such a
huge fan of my homepod i have them in
every single room and now the fact that
you can get a home pod for 99
is incredible let's open it up
look it's i love these colors it's so
great the suspense
oh my god whoa
what look at
oh
my it's a baby
i have to be very careful
this is so small
it's about the size of a softball
i used to be a fast pitcher
it's almost actually about the same
weight too
like if we have this
cable like look at this size comparison
it's like not even a comparison this
thing is so tiny
oh wow
i do have two of them which will allow
you to do a nice stereo pair oh look at
that little apple logo on the bottom is
there an apple there is
what do you know
let's plug this in
look at this braided cable
very very nice i like that this is a
usb-c cable as opposed to an actual plug
is there something else in here there is
look we have more things
it does include a wall charger
it is plugged in
oh
[Music]
look it's ready
homepod mini setup look at that oh my
gosh hi oh i can't wait to talk to you
it's been a while since i've talked to
anybody other than tyler for a very long
time
where are we going to set this up we're
going to set this up in let's just say
we're gonna set it up in the basement
basement homepod i don't have a basement
you can enable personal requests which
means i can have siri read my text
messages i can send messages just got a
little notification here that says siri
for everyone siri can recognize the
voices of each person in the home
provide access to music reminders
calendar and more invite people to your
home in the home app after setup all
right should i plug in this dude too oh
look at that you oh you missed it okay
pod is ready play third eye blind
wow
oh my gosh
i'm gonna get a copyright strike but
this is so loud can you believe how loud
that is no holy
moly the just there's hardly any
distortion like that sounds so that was
all the way up
[Music]
this is only 99
and it sounds
like a million bucks
like i don't need to have this big home
pot in every single room now because a
lot of my rooms are fairly small and
this would be
perfect
so the homepod mini is 99 the homepod
homepod is 2.99 obviously the homepod is
much larger so there's a lot more room
for larger drivers and the sound quality
is better in this one but that's not to
take away from the fact that this small
tiny little device is putting out
incredible sound like i was honestly
very surprised
so the new mini has a four microphone
design and these are used to detect when
you say hey
s and the fourth is used for echo
cancellation so that siri is able to
hear you even when it's noisy or if
music is playing now this little device
is surprisingly powerful with the s5
chip and a full range driver delivering
some really impressive sound much like
the full size homepod the top is touch
sensitive so you can use the surface to
play pause double tap for the next track
you triple tap for the previous track
and then you can press and hold to
activate siri there's also some little
plus and minus buttons here that you can
see and those you can adjust the volume
but you can also do this with your voice
by simply saying hey
turn up the volume turn the volume down
turn the volume to 15
turn up the volume to 50 if you're using
home pod in a household where there's
multiple people when you have your
family connected to it it'll be able to
recognize the voices of each family
member so that they'll be able to have
access to all of their playlists and
their recommendations so siri is
constantly learning who's talking to her
or him you can always change the siri
voice since i do have a lot of home pods
in my house it's kind of crazy because
anytime i tell her to play music
everywhere the entire house just
automatically starts playing music
another cool thing that i wanted to call
attention to is the fact that the
homepod mini is one of the first apple
devices to have thread support and
nanoleaf just launched some new light
bulbs that are also thread enabled which
will allow more compatibility with more
internet of things devices so i have the
nanoleaf app ready i've got a light
ready let's open this up and set it up
i'm so excited about these i love nano
leaf they have so many cool products
oh it's a little warm
now swap it out now swap it out now swap
it out look at that old tech
we're going to be able to change the
colors
we're going to be able to do so many
things with this like turn it off and
turn it on and change the colors
add to home
let's do it connecting make sure it
stays connected oh where this is we're
doing this living room little light i
want it to turn on when i arrive home
turn off when i leave turn off little
light
turn on little light
okay the little light is on
turn off little light
[Music]
okay the little light is off
little light
it's a little light let's add the apple
look at this look at this what color we
want little light turn little light blue
got it
i didn't even know if that was gonna
work turn little light pink
okay another thing that you could do
with these is set them up as a stereo
pair you were also able to do this with
the previous home pods but it's really
cool because now these fit so much
better right here on my tv entertainment
center you now have the ability with
just these two home pods to have that
stereo sound and have a much more
immersive experience you'll be able to
use a u1 equipped phone and that will
allow you to be able to just kind of
hold your phone up next to the homepod
and it'll transfer the music or your
phone call or your podcast so this is
going to be kind of neat because if
you're in your car listening to your
music or if you're on a phone call and
you come into the house and your homepod
recognizes that your phone is near it
it'll automatically transfer whatever it
is that you're listening to
right to your homepod one thing that i
use my homepod for
more often than i'd like to admit is to
find my iphone find my iphone just a
moment i found three iphones nearby
which one
pig phone pig face
or iphone
surprise
it's right here intercom is a really fun
feature that i've been using to further
my quarantine problem of talking to
myself so now i'm talking to myself
through my homepods and my phone and
this is kind of interesting because i'm
able to use intercom on my phone on my
apple watch by telling siri to hey
intercom everyone and then i say
whatever message that i want to say and
it's cool because this will show up
right here on my phone and then i can
also use my phone to respond and then
that can also go throughout my entire
house and activate on every single
homepod are you having a good day hmm
i don't have an answer for that oh is
there something else i can help with
that is now going to be my answer
when anybody asks you how i'm doing
i don't have an answer for that is there
something else that you would like to
ask me
hey justine how you doing
so i know this was just a quick look at
the new homepod midi but i'm very
excited about this because this is kind
of changing the way that we're able to
interact with our devices and at a much
lower price point this is only 99 which
is still on the higher end for some of
these smart speaker devices but if you
are looking to keep this sort of in the
apple ecosystem if you want a good
speaker if you want to have access to
siri and it will have those updates with
the u1 chip hopefully very soon well
thank you guys so much for watching as
always i will see you in the next video
and if you haven't subscribed please do
so and hit the bell so you'll be
notified when i post a new video and i
will see you guys in the next one
did you do that
did you do that i didn't do that shut up
yes you did so i think what happened is
are you doing no you're shut up are you
dude are you messing with me no you're
doing it i'm not connecting to your
paws yeah but you could airplane to it
no but i didn't he did
[Music]